-Guys, there was a new episode
of "Below Deck" on Monday,
and I love that show.
I don't think anyone knows i
better than me
because that is my exact -
Leslie J--!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Leslie Jones, everybody!
Leslie Jones! Leslie!
What? What are you --
-Nobody knows "Below Deck"
more than me.
-Oh, really?
-Trust. Trust.
-There's only one way
to settle this.
it's time for a one-second qui
"Below Deck" edition.
Here we go.
♪♪ -One-second quiz,
"Below Deck" edition ♪♪
-Ha!
-Here's how it works.
We're going to play a video clip
from an episode of "Below Deck,"
but it's gonna be
just one second long.
First one of us to hit
this button has to say
what is happening in that scene.
If we get it right,
we get a point.
Ready for this?
Let's see the first clip.
-Kate, where are you going
-Oh!
-I got it.
That's when Kate quits her job
-You're cheating.
-I didn't cheat!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's Kate Chastain,
the great Kate Chastain.
-I love Kate.
-Me too. She walked out.
-She walked out. She a boss!
-"Don't follow me."
-"Don't follow me!"
-That's right.
-I love Kate.
-I love Kate too. Me too.
Alright. Next clip.
-Oh, my God! Oh!
-That's when the too drunk gir
got too drunk on the islan
and they had to bring her back
on the plastic boat.
[ Ding! ]
-That's right.
That's right.
And she was like,
"I didn't pay for this.
I didn't pay for
this whole thing."
[ Mumbling ]
-Like, please go get some help
[ Laughter ]
-Let's take a look at
our next clip. Here we go.
-What did you hear?
-Oh!
-My favorite scene --
Captain Lee coming to
straighten them out
with no shirt on.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I'm saying?
That's like Daddy getting up i
the middle of the night like
"Why y'all in this room,
making all this noise,
when I'm trying to sleep?!
Go to sleep!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Captain Lee!
-Oh, I love that.
Alright, final round.
This one is worth 1,000 points
-1,000?
-Yep. Here it is.
-When did it get that --
-Here we go.
You didn't even see it!
You pressed it
before it came on!
You pressed before --
Stop doing that!
Stop doing that! Stop, stop!
Stop doing that.
-I know what it is.
-What?
-That's when stupid Brian hi
his knee and then the guy had to
come on the boat and give hi
some antibiotics
and it still didn't work though.
[ Ding! ]
-That's right. That's right.
You won.
Wow. I want to talk more later
You win. Leslie Jones, everyone.
We will see you later.